and i was in san francisco and they had
a you know what is it what you've been
there
lucas's
thing
it's where all the lucas stuff is uh the
san francisco
yeah the procedures huh
anyway i was there that's what lucasfilm
is yeah yeah yeah and i okay then i was
at lucasfilm yeah and then i'm asking
you i'm not telling you huh you're
asking me yeah you were throwing it
around like i should know what am i i
like the movies i don't know the [__]
do you have kevin smith's phone number
because i could ask him
i'm just saying it seems like something
you would know no not at all i'm an
outsider bro you think i'm [__] tight
with lucasfilm and [__] if i was how
come i am how did you get married it is
terrible we were mixing a movie there at
the time i did it illegally we didn't
ask oh wow yeah it wasn't like george
lucas what married us and [__] like i
asked the mixers i was like
if i get married here should i ask
somebody they're like don't apologize
later on just do it forget it so we
eloped
and then he found out later on i was
like oh who got married
wait
the film belongs to me not the fans
[Laughter]
greedo shot first
wow okay
he's he's controversial but he's cute
i can't say no to the guy he's adorable
my responsibility is to my vision not
the fans
[Laughter]
can we do a podcast where um we're like
you think about george lucas
and you just make me laugh the whole
time
that's genius
[Music]